foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing 10 things you might have
missed in the Half-Blood Prince movie
the Half Blood Prince introduced us to a
whole new site to Voldemort that we had
rarely seen before Tom Riddle's past
thanks to Dumbledore's memories and
Professor slugcorn's recollection we
were granted a glimpse into Voldemort's
early years as a wizard and how he
eventually learned the secrets of
creating horcruxes throughout the film
though you might have missed some of
these smaller details that make the
Wizarding World so rich so today let's
take a deep dive and check out 10 of
these smaller bids from the Half-Blood
Prince that might have snuck by you
let's get into it 10. why Harry was sick
learning how to operate was actually
quite the skill during the time of
newt's Commander the magical Congress to
the United States regularly hired
official tools to oversee Apparition
exams and judge Wizards and witches on
their skill level and the students of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and was a
tree weren't too different under the
direction of Headmaster Albus Dumbledore
the students of Hogwarts learned
Apparition in their sixth year but it
wasn't a main part of the curriculum it
was an optional class that many chose to
enroll in by the time Wizards and
witches turned 17 they could finally
test themselves in an apparition test
and receive a license but during the
events of the Half-Blood Prince Harry
Potter's own inexperience with the spell
was put on display when he became sick
immediately after taking a journey via
Apparition nine seven stones four seven
horcruxes we received a red glimpse into
Voldemort's past when Albus Dumbledore
shared the memories of his visit to the
young with his orphanage decades earlier
while there Dumbledore heard the
troubling tale of the boy no known as
Tom Riddle and when the Aged wizard went
to Riddle's room to talk to the young
sorcerer one-on-one he learned even more
but if you looked carefully at Riddle's
private quarters you might have noticed
there was a nod to the seven horcruxes
he would eventually produce after
learning about The Relic at Hogwarts on
his window ledge Tom had collected a
series of seven stones as you might have
heard me mention before the number seven
has special significance in the magical
community and was even proven to be more
powerful than other integers by a famous
13th century wedge the fact that
Voldemort had collected seven stones was
no coincidence eight Minerva
mcgonagall's other battle Minerva
McGonagall was forced to help lead
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and was a
dream during Harry Potter's sixth year
at The Institute for much of the film
Albus Dumbledore was busy chasing down
Voldemort's horcruxes across the British
Countryside and on a more personal note
the wizard was consumed with fears about
his eventual death he had foolishly
warned mavola gaunt's ring an item that
cursed Albus Dumbledore with an
unbreakable curse Albus knew he would
die soon but he wasn't sure if Harry
Potter and the brave Wizards he would
leave behind were strong enough to
defeat Voldemort in his absence but
while Professor McGonagall did double
duty as an administrator the actress who
portrayed her Maggie Smith fought her
own battle during the filming of this
sixth Potter movie Smith had been
diagnosed with breast cancer and in
between shooting scenes she underwent
procedures that would allow her to
eventually put the disease into
remission 7. Harry Potter's son appears
casting in the Harry Potter films has
always been a bit wonky unlike other
massive cinematic universes where the
cast were primarily made up of adults
the Harry Potter films were composed of
young British actors that presented its
own series of challenges and oftentimes
would result in the film because double
dipping at times the same exact actor or
actress would be called back to portray
a completely different actor in later
Harry Potter films this much was true
when Arthur Bowen was cast as a nameless
extra in the Half-Blood Prince and later
assumed the role of Albus Severus Potter
in the Deathly Hallows part 2's epilogue
6. Ginny Weasley's artwork the borough
was the name for the Weasley family's
house although it was a tall towering
uneven structure you'd be wrong to think
that it was any less of a home than
Ron's friends and peers within the
borough the Weasley parents Arthur and
Molly raised their Motley Crew of
children and even bought Harry Potter in
as one of their own during the creation
of the set for the home and the Half
Blood Prince some of the actors who
portrayed the Weasleys even helped
decorate the house namely Bonnie Wright
the actress behind Ginny Weasley helped
set designers bring the borrow an actual
lived-in feeling 5. horcrux Easter egg
while watching Albus Dumbledore's
memories of a young Tom Riddle you'll
find more than a callback to the seven
horcruxes that Voldemort would
eventually produce on one of the walls
of Riddle's room there's a black and
white photo of a dangerous chunk of
ocean where Voldemort would hide one of
his horcruxes to those familiar with the
British Coast you'd recognize that the
picture captured the Cliffs of MOA the
place where the Potter filmmakers
decided to place the cave that held the
Inn fairy 4. slughorns wand Professor
Slughorn was one of the newest members
of Hogwarts staff during the events of
the Half-Blood Prince infamously
Slughorn was one of the professors who
foolishly trusted the young Tom Riddle
and even divulged some of these secrets
the dark arts that Voldemort would later
use to create his horcruxes but despite
all the mistakes in his past Slughorn
never really seemed like the malevolent
sword instead much like gilderoy
Lockhart Slughorn was motivated by his
own ego he wanted to be venerated as a
great master of magic and he wanted to
surround himself with the smartest
up-and-coming magic users that he could
find seemingly showcasing his good
nature slughorn's wand wasn't
particularly terrifying it was a simple
gaudy piece of wood with a slug's head
at the very temp while other Wizards
might have tried to flee from such a
strange name Slughorn embraced it 3.
stotherin's green when Professor
Slughorn revealed the secrets of dark
magic to a young Tom Riddle did you
happen to notice what color the memories
were filled with it doesn't take a
Discerning viewer to note that the room
was cast in a green Hue just like the
filmmakers had utilized Green in past
films the color was specifically placed
in this scene to emphasize Voldemort's
role in Southern's Legacy not only was
he the school co-founders Heir but he
was also the greatest dark wizard that
would come out of England and perhaps
all the world 2. Voldemort actors are
related Harry Potter and the Half-Blood
Prince showcased Lord Voldemort at
multiple periods in his life the oldest
and most terrifying version of the
villain was portrayed by Rafe fines but
did you know that he was actually
related to one of the other actors who
was cast as Tom Riddle the young of
Voldemort was actually portrayed by Hero
finds Tiffin hero is rafe's nephew and
since he's several decades younger than
his uncle he was the perfect age to
fulfill the part thankfully Heroes
acting chops were more than up to the
challenge as his version of a young Tom
Riddle was bone chillingly scary one
Slughorn calls Ron rupid the list of
things you might have missed is filled
with small factoids about Professor
Slughorn so I thought we'd finished out
with one more about the infamous
instructor if you watch the film you
might have noticed that Slughorn had
tried to get close and cozy with the
most promising students at Hogwarts as
we already mentioned slug Contigo was
the only really evil thing about the man
and he would often count the
accomplishments of his students as his
own in a way so he tried to collect as
many up-and-coming Wizards and witches
to his side as possible so that he could
bring up their accomplishments in
conversations in the future and casually
let people know that he was their
teacher but with so much time and
attention given to the smartest children
at Hogwarts Slughorn couldn't spare much
time for the mediocre so when Ron
Weasley came to Slughorn alongside Harry
it wasn't uncommon for the professor to
completely forget who the youngest
Weasley boy was at one point he even
called Ron Rupert which was a slide joke
by the filmmakers since Rupert Grint was
the ACT her who portrayed him well there
you have it 10 things you might have
missed from Harry Potter and the
Half-Blood Prince how many of these did
you know how many of them were
completely unknown let me know in the
comments below and as always I'm sure
there is quite a bit more in this film
for you to discover so make sure you
share your findings with us as well and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember happiness can be
found even in the darkest of times if
one only remembers to turn on the light
[Music]